This is the retro on the database migration. Three weeks late, but here we are.
I want to keep it to what we'd do differently, not who did what.
The honest headline is the rollback took four hours when we'd budgeted forty minutes.
We tested rollback on a copy of staging, and staging had about a twentieth of the data.
That's the real lesson for me. We tested the procedure but not at the size it had to work at.
Agreed. So the action is we rehearse against a production-sized snapshot before the next one.
That needs infrastructure we don't have. Restoring a production snapshot takes most of a day.
Then that's the cost. I'd rather spend a day rehearsing than four hours failing.
I'll back that. Dan, can you scope what a production-sized rehearsal environment needs?
I can scope it. I can't build it this sprint, I'm on rollback tooling.
Scope only. We'll decide whether to fund it once we know the number.
Second thing — we had no way to tell how far through the migration we were.
For two hours nobody could answer whether it was progressing or stuck.
That's fair. Progress reporting on long-running jobs is a genuine gap.
Add it to the list, but I don't think it blocks the next migration.
So: rehearse at production size, scope the environment, and progress reporting when we can.
Good. And the bug count is down from thirty-one to nine, which is quotable now.